alors les messieurs tu as vraiment à
temps plein je sais pas peut-être alors
on a on à victor mercier et geoffrey de
gaulle à vous étiez dans la même saison
et donc shop top chef saison 9
alors pour vous victor victor quelle
heure exactement viktor bout c'est un
une réussite bah ça s'est très bien
passé où il après ça s'est très bien
passé on soit bas il ya un avons un réel
avant et un après ou alors aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous apportez top chef bah
là je veux ouvrir un restaurant est par
exemple ne serait ce qu'à les voir un
banquier
après top chef c'est pas du tout là vers
une façon enfin c'est pas du tout la
même réception que si on jamais rien
fait ouais moi on veut c'est même mon
banquier qui m'a poussé à ouvrir le
restaurant 10 ans et maintenant c'est
fou
donc voilà donc ça c'est ça c'est
évident après médiatiquement c'est vrai
qu'on est un peu plus présent que si on
avait réagi
voilà on vous prend plus au sérieux
quand vous dites on vous avait fait
objet bien sûr et vous aviez terminé
convient et perdu en finale finalistes
exactement donc vous savez fait un très
gros parcours en plus et donc ses modes
banques et quand il vous a vu finaliste
si vous appelez vous a dit bonjour voila
on va on va y aller voilà donc il vous a
suivi vous financent le restaurant après
il ya évidemment bien sûr mais ouais
ouais ça c'est beau c'est grand show est
pas voulu faire le restaurant avant de
dallas n'ont maintenant gt gt le
candidat un peu perdu qui mettrait alors
et vous plaisait beaucoup à mathieu oui
on s'est rencontré la chance de ce 200
il alors les rodéos nouveau rien à voir
je vous étiez aussi candidate oble chef
saison 9
et c'est pas la même expérience qu au
fond qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ce
alors oui forcément ça se passe très
bien pour lui puisque son banquier même
là le pousse à ouvrir un resto vous
pourquoi ça vous a plombé ce que ça vous
a réellement plombé ça m'a pas plomber
mais ça n'a pas réellement changé ma vie
on va être donc ça n'a pas bougé quoi
pas vraiment je pense que top chef
ça change pour pour les finalistes tu
peux faire un beau parcours avoir les
meilleures critiques des meilleurs chefs
de france après voilà moi j'ai si vous
étiez déçu de l'ambiance au sein des
équipes de certaines séquences
voilà qui sont mises en scène par la
production c'est ça qui vous dérange
c'était le côté télé après je m'y
attendais mais je pensais pas que
c'était à ce point là on fait avec quoi
c'était quoi je jure quoi c'était genre
bah tu rates ton mec tu peux la refaire
courte en gros un moment sur dernière
chance avec macho et on me disais ouais
tu dis lui que tu va le défoncer machin
et vie dit non parce que je m'entends
bien en gros on rentre chez toi alors
que c'est si tu veux pas être dans la
compet away d'argent après ait parlé
comme ça pour ma part
et ouais mais ces dates et les ouais
c'est ça ils veulent tout mettre en
scène et c'est normal ouais quand c'est
trop plat mais je pensais pas que
c'était à ce point c'est vrai alors elle
peut pas vraiment dire vos victoires
vous l'avez senti cette ce côté là très
mise en scène encore une fois c'est de
la télévision donc si c'était ennuyeux à
regarder s'il se passait rien là je
pense que les gens regardent mais pas sa
frappe à 3 millions d'audience
alors hier ya quelqu'un qui est qui a
fait beaucoup parler sa ruse lorient
exactement sur yon donc il est il était
actif sur la chef hélène darroze
apparemment c'est grave son délire mais
en che ce cas et sur le délire de
florian regarder si je peux être pris
dans une brionne phare la séduction je
dirais pas non
en plus j'ai beaucoup de respect pour la
chaîne da ros et gérer ses doutes il
pourra rien faire c'est ce qu'en pas de
ma faute
je sens qu'on va y avoir un feeling voir
quelque chose c'est sûr ça m'a bocce
alors attention qui sait que tu essayes
de séduire en faisant ce joli plat là
moi je vais pas vous mentir chaque fois
c'est vous 6 en trompe l'oeil et à la
hauteur de sa promesse moi je vais pas
dire non et même pour berson comme ça un
de vos frais l'an dernier oui alors non
mais évidemment je pense vraiment que
c'est un tremplin après oui bien sûr et
j'adore cette émission c'est une
émission de télévision
donc je ne remet pas du tout en cause
votre talent mais c'est sûr que côté un
beau garçon c'est plutôt bien si vert
final à la fin d'une année où il y avait
une jeune asiatique jeudi qui n'ont qui
était très très très joli et je me
souviens en coulisse pourrait être un
petit peu aller que les chefs disait
n'était pas forcément forcément la
meilleure mais c'était une jolie fille
ça manquait deux filles à la fin s'il ya
que des garçons c'est un souci est donc
ils l'ont fait avant c'est un petit peu
plus quand même mais c'est de la télé
ballard est de la parole pas du tout
même si certaines fait le gagnant de
l'année dernière et pas été pas le plus
beau des gars c'est parce qu'on dit pas
que oui non mais je trouve que dans
cette émission c'est la mécanique qui
est la star des candidats aussi bon
soit-il moi je serais incapable de citer
un seul nom de candidat donc à gagner
dans les dix dernières années non plus
n'ont jamais les émissions garçons
j'adore n'y a pas de choix et je suis
très admiratif de ce que vous faites
mais c'est vrai que les émissions de
cuisine je préfère regarder des fruits
en garde sur rtl en mer est ce que si
norbert n'avait pas été aussi car il
adore verra d'or vous aimez caricatural
dans sa façon de faire était ça il
aurait été aussi loin
il est très bon au président rudy place
justement on à nouveau un peu le nouveau
norbert cette année c'est marouane il a
il a des expressions bien à lui comme
norbert lambert que j'embrasse qui est
exceptionnel rien
je suis pas bien là je transpire du
saindoux gérer ce qui commence à sentir
l'anguille fumée et on n'est pas bien
grave
bonjour mais roanne pro chef merouane
c'est quoi d'autant plus tôt berton que
brossard breton qui a voulu pêche et de
l'assemblée qui s'est retrouvé un corps
à gré donc là c'est bon on est soulagés
les garants lâché gaz et l'âge et la
lnah ski freestyle
on y va jalinot fait de la cuisine bon
j'arrête de faire le con quand même
auteur vous avez des contacts avec
hélène darroze autres chefs encore ou
pas du tout alors ces sachets five à
voter oui parce que vous souhaitiez e
etchebest mais alors vous avez des
contacts avec la sueur bien sûr même
avec les chefs darroze aussi offert
texto quoi ils sont textos mais pas même
des appels à la raison ils sont ici vous
l'auriez vous maintenant après fait plus
le respect chef a bien sûr quand vint
donc ouais c'est ne voit pas lui envoyer
un message
ah ouais tu fais bien vous respectez
vrai je pense c'est bon oui alors oui
très vite mais on peut quand même dire
que ce casting est ouf
moi je me suis régalé hier et pas
seulement pour florian parce qu'on s'est
appelée entre copines en disant t'as vu
comment il est beau gosse est tout à
fait en même temps il y avait un bras
elle qui était vachement bien il ya
surtout tous les candidats ont un talent
en cuisine les hallucinants moi j'ai
maintenant regarder les émotions
bah si c'est quand même drôle si shawn
ryan
c'est irréel c'est hyper qui forge alors
comme chaque année on a eu le droit ou
candidats aussi qu'un petit peu le bout
la wii sébastien vous allez voir quand
il se décrit déjà c'est tout en modestie
c'est l'hôtel de l'ange je fais top chef
pour voir jusqu'où je peux aller et de
mon atout dans le concours je pense et
ma persévérance et perfectionniste et je
vais toujours arriver au bourget une
grosse clientèle
los angeles à hong kong j'ai déjà assez
ri villiers en fait en réalité j'ai pas
de point faible il faut mélanger flics
et je te laisse et jean françois piège
et seulement je ne ferai jamais les
choses à moitié
[Applaudissements]
moi je trouve que c'est pas du tout un
tremplin pour deux raisons parce que en
fait c'est une télé réalité c'est
scénarisé comme vous disais mais comme
dans toutes les téléréalités ya plein de
laissés pour compte qu'on abandonne
totalement comme ici mais je suis
presque à quelques vainqueurs et encore
je suis désolé moi j'en connais un un
des vainqueurs de la saison c'est xavier
pincemin mais il avait du talent il
avait un talent extraordinaire avançant
toxa l'effacement ce n'est pas le frère
de gueule il serait ultra connus
aujourd'hui sans top chef s'est immergé
alors lumière l'évêque série mafiosa
casse mais c'est aussi bête de dire que
de voice ou de messages n'est pas un
tremplin pour leur classe et une
exposition le maquis bah oui de se
montrer montrer comment il fait
franchement pour le coup et j'aime pas
les missions - mais là c'est très dur il
y en a c'est qu'on ne connaît plus des
enseignants nous fait saliver double top
chef ne fait pas la promesse de les
mettre en lumière et change élargi leurs
éditions brill la grippe a c'est vrai
mais elle est beaucoup et très juste à
ça mais vous étiez malade vous avez un
coup sur la tête aussi pour ça remis les
choses en place
sauf que tuft a une vertu pendant très
longtemps les métiers de la restauration
avait une image pas très populaire d'ad
top chef donne une image un peu glamour
et d'ailleurs c'est fou l'engouement on
retrouve aujourd'hui devant vous mais
les tremplins lui vocation également
hockey à ces quatre gagnants ont été
étoilé par l'umih parle guy à
faire des pétitions démissionner
cinquante deux enfants qui sont nés
avant le bonheur est dans le pré le seul
souci qu'il ya c'est que évidemment ils
sont tous très très bon au top chef
manager compris quelque chose c'est pour
que pour exister elle est loin d être
mises en lumière dans le vent la caméra
il faut faire le chanvre est donc là on
a un nouveau norbert un peu quand il dit
je fais d'ananas et tout ça c'est comme
dans les anges de la télé réalité la
dixième année avec précision la petite
phrase ils iront plus loin que l'étendue
taille du coup sûr est ce que c'est vrai
victor et oui ce qu'on doit faire le
choix vous faites un peu le show on vous
pousse à faire le nom je pense pas qu'on
doit faire le show absolument mais par
contre on est mis dans des conditions
qui nous font qui nous pousse un peu
dans leurs retranchements et qui du coup
c'est vrai nous met en difficulté donc
nous faut sortir un peu de la zone de
confort alors on va voir ce qu'on sait
très bien que ce soit c'est très bien
mais c'est vrai que tu as raison sans
vrai tremplin
j'avais tremplins après le métier de
cuisinier derrière qui que ce soit s'il
tremplin si le mec est courageux bon et
c'est bien sûr série b y en avait mais
ça ne l'est en blouson de dollars
cusiniers ou pas ta question pourquoi
pas tremplin évidemment mais derrière
pour faire la carrière et pour tenir la
roue et pour tout ça c'est beaucoup de
boulot parce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs l'émission d'octobre à
juillet dans 44 ans avait préparé de
leur moto